do you think it's possible to
automatically discover the predicates
this so you basically said that the
essence of intelligence is the discovery
of good predicates yeah now the natural
question is you know that's what
Einstein was good at doing in physics
can we make machines do these kinds of
discovery of good predicates or is this
ultimately a human endeavor
yes I don't know I don't think that
machine can do because according to
theory but with conversions any function
from hill the space can be predicates
so you have infinite number of
predicates in upper in and before you
don't know which predicate is good on
wish but whatever prop show and why
people call it breakthrough that there
is not too many predicates which cover
most of situation happens in the world
so there's a sea of predicates and most
of the only a small amount are useful
for the kinds of things that happen in
the world I think that I would say only
small part of predicates very useful
useful all of all of them only very few
are what we should let's call them good
predicates very good predictor very good
predicates so can we linger on it what's
your intuition why is it hard for a
machine to discover good predicates I
even in my talk described have to do
predicates have to find new predicate
I'm not sure that it is very good what
is you're proposing it up no in my talk
I gave example for diabetes they billion
won when we achieve some percent so then
the looking for area
where
some sort of predicate each I formulate
does not keeps invariant so if it
doesn't keep I train my data I select on
the function which keeps this invariant
and when I did it I improve my
performance I can looking for this
predicate I know technically have to do
that and you can of course do it using
machine but I am NOT shows that video
instructs the smartest predicate but
this is the allow me linger on it
because that's the essence that's the
challenge that is artificial that's
that's the human level intelligence that
we seek is the discovery of these good
predicates you've talked about deep
learning as a way to the predicates they
use and the functions are mediocre you
can find better ones let's talk about
deep learning sure let's do I know only
yawns laocoön convolutional network and
what else
I don't know energy very simple
convolution there's not much else eleven
right yes I can do it like that one this
one predicates it is convolution is a
single predicate it's single it's it's
single predict yes because you know
exactly you take the derivative for
translational and predicate ly this
should should be kept so that's a single
predicate humans discovered that one or
least note that is every stick not too
many predicates and that this big story
because he undid it 25 years ago and
nothing so clear was added to to to deep
network and then I don't understand why
we should talk about deep network
instead of talking about piecewise
linear functions
which keeps us pretty cake or the you
know a counter-argument is that maybe
the amount of predicates necessary to
solve general intelligence say in space
of images during efficient recognition
of handwritten digits is very small and
so we shouldn't be so obsessed about
finding we'll find other good predicates
like convolution for example you know
there's there has been other
advancements like if you look at the
work with attention there's attentional
mechanisms in especially used in natural
language focusing the the network's
ability to to learn at which part of the
input to look at the thing is there's
other things besides predicates that are
important for the actual engineering
mechanism of showing how much you can
really do given such these predicates I
I mean that's essentially the work of
deep learning is constructing
architectures that are able to be given
the training data to be able to converge
towards a function they can approximate
can keep generalize well that's an
engineering problem oh yeah I understand
but let's talk not on emotional level
but on a mathematical level you have set
of piecewise linear functions it is all
possible neural networks
it's just piecewise linear functions
this is many many pieces large large
number to specify exactly but very large
very large almost what is still large is
to simpler than second volution al susan
reproducing kernel Hilbert space H have
a hilda's set of paths what's Hilbert
space its space with infinite number of
coordinates a function for expansion
something
so it's much richer so and when I
talking about closed-form solution like
lot talking about this set of function
not piecewise linear set which is
particular case if it's small for the
neural networks is a small part of the
space your talk a function is small say
a small set of functions they let me
take that but it is fine which is fine I
don't want to discuss a small or big
retaken value so you have some set of
functions so know when you're trying to
create a hiccup Chi you would like to
create admissible set of function which
all your tricks to use not all functions
but some subset of the set of functions
say when you introducing convolutional
net it is way to make this subset useful
for you but from my point of view
convolutional it is something you want
to keep some invariants say translation
invariance but now if you understand
this and you cannot explain on the level
of I guess what neural network does you
should agree is it it is much better to
have a set of functions as I say this
set of functions should be admissible it
must keep season variances invariant and
that invalid you know that as soon as
you incorporate new invariant set of
function because smaller and smaller and
smaller but all the invariants are
specified by you the human yeah but what
I am hope that there is a standard
predicate like prop saw that
that's what I want to find four digit
recognition if they start it is
completely new area what is intelligence
about on the level
starting from from plotters idea what is
vault of ideas so and I believe that is
not too many yeah but you know it is
amusing that mathematician doing
something in their own network in in
general function but people from
literature from art she uses all the
time
that's right in the audience saying say
it is great of how people describe music
we should learn from that in something
on this level but so why volodymyr probe
who was just theoretical who study
theoretical literature he found that you
know let me throw that right back at you
because there's a little bit of a that's
less mathematical and more emotional
philosophical Vladimir Propp I mean he
wasn't doing math no and you just said
an another emotional statement which is
you believe that this Plato world of
ideas is small I hope I hope do you do
what's your intuition of we can linger
on it you know about is not just small
or big I know
exactly then when I introducing some
predicates I decreased set of functions
but my goal to degree set of function
much by as much as pass by as much as
possible
good predicate which which does this
Zener should chosen next predicate which
does each degree set as much as possible
so set of good predicates it is such
that they decrease this amount of
admissible functions of each good
predicate signal
can reduces the set of admissible
functions that they're naturally should
not be that many PR predicates no but
but if you reduce very well the VC
dimension of the function of admissible
set of function is small and you need
not too much training data to do well
and VC dimension by the way is some
measure of capacity of this set of
function right
roughly speaking how many function in
this set so you're decreasing decreasing
and it might easy for you to find
function you're looking for that the
most important part to create good
admissible set of functions and it
probably there are many ways but the
good predicated says that they can do
that so let's for for for this duck you
should know a little bit about done
because what are the what is the three
fundamental laws of ducks looks like the
dog swims like a duck and quacks again
you should know something about ducks to
me not necessarily looks like a horse so
so good it's nice it generalizes yes
from the talk look like Elliott and make
sound like horse and something in run
like horse and and moves like horse
it is generally it is general predicate
that this applied to dock but for dock
you can say play chess like that
you cannot say play chess why not see
you're saying you can put it that would
not be a good no you're not reduce a lot
of you not do yeah yeah even averages
cell function so you get the story is
formal story with a magical story is
that you can use any function you want
as a predicate but some of them are good
some of them are not because some of
them reduce a lot of functions the
admissible setter some of them but the
question is I'll probably keep asking
this question but how do we find
and subscribe what's your intuition when
handwritten hearing recognition how do
we find the answer to your challenge
yeah yeah I understand it's like that I
understand what what what defined what
it means I'm a new predicate yeah like
guy who understand music can say this
worth which he described him when he
listened to music he understand music he
use not too many different or you can do
like probe you can make collection what
you're talking about music about Z's
about that it's not too many different
situations he described because you
mentioned vitomir proper boys let me
just mention there's a sequence of of
thirty-one structural notions they're
common in stories and I think you called
units units and I think they resonate I
mean it starts just a given example
abstention a member of the hero's
community a family leaves the security
of the home environment then it goes to
the interdiction or forbidding edict or
command is passed upon the hero don't go
there don't do this the heroes warn
against some action then step three
violate violation of interdiction brace
you know break the rules break out on
your own then reconnaissance the villain
makes an effort to attain knowledge
needing to fulfill their plot so on it
goes on like this ends ends in a wedding
number 31 your happily ever after no he
just gave description of all situation
he understands this vault of fossils ya
know for not focus it photos of stories
and this story is not in just for tales
the stories in detective serials as well
and probably in our lives will probably
live resist at the ends a zero jet this
predicate is good for different
situation from movie from jet for for
movie
by the way there's also criticism right
there's an other way to interpret
narratives from Claude lévi-strauss
Kingdom I am not in this business and I
know it's theoretical literature but
looking in very nice it's always the the
the philosopher yeah yeah but at least
there is a units it's not too many units
that can describe but that I probably
gives another unit or in other way
exactly another another set of unasyn
not a set of predicates it does not
matter whole but they exist
probably my my question is whether given
those units whether without our human
brains to interpret these units they
would still hold as much power as I have
meaning are those units enough when we
give them to the alien species let me
ask you do you understand digital
calvini digit images no I don't know no
or when you can recognize this digit
images that you understand yes you
understand characters you understand no
no no no I I it's it's the imitation
versus understanding question because I
don't understand the mechanism by which
I don't know no I'm not talking about
I'm talking about three decades you
understand that it involves symmetry
maybe structure might be something cuz i
cannot form a wait i just was able to
find symmetries negative symmetries
that's really good
so this is a good line I feel like I
understand the basic elements of what
makes a good hand recognition system my
own like symmetry connects with me it
seems like that's a very powerful
predicate my question is is there a lot
more going on that we're not able to
introspect maybe I need to be able to
understand
huge amount in the world of ideas
thousands of predicates millions of
predicates in order to do hand
recognition I don't think so say you're
you know boast your hope and your
intuition very flippantly enough you're
using digits you're using examples as
well theory says that if you will use
all possible functions from Hilde space
all possible predicates you don't need
training date you just will have
admissible set of functions which
contain one function yes so the
trade-off is when you're not using all
predicates you're only using a few good
practice you need to have some training
data yes those are the more the the more
good practice you have the last training
day exactly that this intelligent blood
still okay I'm gonna keep asking the
same dumb question handwritten
recognition to solve the challenge you
kind of propose a challenge that says we
should be able to get state of the art
amnesty error rates by using very few
sixty maybe fewer examples prediction
what kind of predict is do you think it
was the challenge so people who will
solve this problem that will answer your
answer do you think they'll be able to
answer it
in a human explainable way those are
just new to write function that's it but
so can that function be written I guess
by an automated reasoning system whether
we're talking about a neural network
learning a particular function or
another mechanism no I am NOT against
neural network I am against admissible
set of function which create neural
network you did it by hand you don't you
don't do it by invariance by predicate
vital by by reason
but you'll Noah's can then reverse do
the reverse step of helping you find a
function just as the task of in your
network is is to find a disentangle
representation for example what they
call is just define that one predicate
function has really captured some kind
of essence one not the entire essence
but one very useful essence of this
particular visual space do you think
that's possible like um listen I'm
grasping hoping there's an automated way
to find good predicates right so the
question is what are the mechanisms of
finding good predicates ideas the you
think we should pursue a university
I gave example so find situation where
predicates which you're suggesting
don't create invariant it's like in
physics
first find situation where the existing
theory cannot just explain it
find situation where the existing
theories earlier not explain this to see
finding contradictions final
contradiction and then remove this
contradiction but in my case
what means contradiction you find
function which if you will use this
function you do not keep in conveyance
this was really the process of
discovering contradictions yeah it is
like in physics find situation where you
have contradiction for one of the
property for one of the predicate then
includes this predicate making
invariance
and solve against this problem now you
don't have contradiction but it is not
the best very probably I don't know -
looking for predicates that's just one
way okay that no no it was brute force
way in the brute force way
you